wie wird geld geschaffen woher kommt das
wer profitiert davon und welchem zweck
dient das ist ein geldsystem was ist das
geld hinter dem geldsystem
seit jahrhunderten ist die mechanik des
geldsystems vor den neugierigen blicken
der bevölkerung verborgen geblieben doch
seine auswirkungen sowohl auf nationaler
als auch auf internationaler ebene sind
vielleicht unübertroffen denn das
finanzsystem schafft die grundlage für
internationale dominanz und nationale
kontrolle
heute da diese grundlagen von krisen
erschüttert werden ist ein offener und
ehrlicher dialog über die zukunft des
geldsystems dringlicher denn je
diese wirtschaftskrise ist wie ein
krebsgeschwür wenn sie nur warten und
warten und denken dass dies von selbst
verschwinden wird genau wie ein
krebsgeschwür wird es wachsen und es
wird irgendwann zu spät sein bereitet
euch vor im moment ist keine zeit für
wunschdenken dass die regierung die
dinge schon regeln wird die regierungen
regieren nicht die welt goldman sachs
regiert die welt
wir stehen am rande einer katastrophe
ungeahnten ausmaßes in konkurrenz
zueinanderstehen korrupte und etablierte
interessen die in den korridoren der
macht lauern für die es keine gründe
gibt ihre privilegien aufzugeben
hat er einen reformplan für das
gesundheitssystem nein hatte einen
reformplan für die polizei nein hat er
einen plan um das defizit zu reduzieren
nein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schauen sie der regierung
[Applaus]
versuchen sie sich zu beruhigen und sich
wie ein erwachsener zu benehmen falls es
ihnen nicht möglich sein sollte dann
verlassen sie die räumlichkeiten raus ja
wir kommen auch ohne sie zurecht
das ist die futterstelle der
bankverbindungen
es ist kein zufall dass auf und
abschwünge um 1700 zu einem echten
zyklischen thema wurden als william
petersen die bank of england gründete
dies ist ein unerträgliches verhalten so
weit ist die öffentlichkeit betrifft
nein es ist nicht lustig
nur in ihrem kopf ist es lustig es ist
überhaupt nicht lustig es ist eine
schande
die einzige lösung revolution
das system ist von natur aus instabil
aufgrund der internationalen
machtverteilung zugunsten der dominanten
parteien denn eigentlich geht es um wie
bekomme ich etwas umsonst
statistische analysen haben gezeigt dass
die währung eines imperiums entwertet
wird wenn es sich seinem eigenen
untergang nähert
es gibt keine anleitung wie dieses ganze
system funktioniert ein forscher der bbc
der an einem dokumentarfilm von robert
besten arbeitet ging zur bank of england
und sagte können sie mir einen leitfaden
geben wir geld geschaffen wird und sie
sagten dort nur nein
dieser dokumentarfilm wird dieses sich
ständig verändernde system die
auswirkungen die es sowohl auf
nationaler als auch auf internationaler
ebene hat untersuchen und erklären
[Musik]
9% und
wie entsteht geld
banknoten und münzen
im jahr 2010 lag die gesamte britische
geldmenge bei 2,15 millionen pfund
2,6 prozent davon waren physisches
bargeld 53 5 milliarden der rest 2,1
billionen oder
97,4 prozent der gesamten geldmenge
waren geschäftsbank geld
die drei prozent des geldes werden durch
die zentralbank geschaffen und wenn man
einen 10 pfund schein herstellt kann man
den an der bank für ihre geldautomaten
verkaufen und die bank muss die zehn
pfund zurückzahlen oder kaufen es wird
kein zins auf das geld erhoben dieses
geld wird dann letztlich an das
finanzministerium weitergeleitet es ist
eine form der beschaffung von
geldmitteln für die regierung das nennt
sich senioren profit den eine regierung
durch die ausgabe von währungen erzielt
die differenz zwischen dem nennwert von
banknoten und münzen und ihren
produktionskosten
für den die bank of england eine zehn
pfund note herstellt kostet es etwa drei
oder vier pence um diesen scheint
tatsächlich zu dürfen sie verkaufen den
geldschein den geschäftsbanken zum
nominalwert von zehn punkt der profit
der unterschied zwischen den druckkosten
und dem verkaufspreis von zehn pfund
geht direkt an das finanzministerium
also jeglicher profit aus der
erschaffung von physischem geld
banknoten geht ans finanzministerium
das reduziert die menge an steuern die
wir zahlen müssen im laufe der letzten
zehn jahre sind so einnahmen von 18
milliarden pfund entstanden
1948 machten banknoten und münzen 17
prozent der gesamten geldmenge aus dies
war ein faktor der zur fähigkeit der
regierung beitrug den wiederaufbau nach
dem krieg zu finanzieren
dazu gehörte auch die gründung des
nationalen gesundheitswesens in nur 60
jahren sind banknoten und münzen auf
weniger als drei prozent geschrumpft
1844 wurden banknoten von privatbanken
geschaffen und die regierung profitiert
nicht davon
vor der industrialisierung gab es
mehrere formen nebeneinander
existierenden geldes und so ist der
aufstieg des staatlich geförderten vier
geld ist ein relativ neues phänomen
in den 1800 40er jahren gab es kein
gesetz den banken zu verbieten ihre
eigenen banknoten zu erschaffen also
haben sie papiergeld herausgegeben das
ihrem kontostand entsprach anstatt mit
schweren metall münzen zu bezahlen
erhielten sie ein stück papier auf dem
stand wie viel sie auf der bank haben
man konnte dann mit diesem papier die
schweren münzen bei der bank abholen
im laufe der zeit war dieses papier geld
genau so gut wie münzgeld die leute
benutzten papiergeld altstadt zur bank
zu gehen oder das echte geld abzuholen
sobald die bank merkten dass ihr
papiergeld die hauptwährungen der
wirtschaft geworden war erkannten sie
dass sie gewinne erzeugen konnten wenn
sie mehr davon herstellten sie können
einfach neue noten drucken sie verleihen
und dafür noch zinsen verlangen und das
haben sie bis in die 1800 40er jahre
gemacht dass sie es ein bisschen zu weit
getrieben haben das verursachte eine
inflation und die stabilisierte die
wirtschaft 1844 hat die konservative
regierung um ein gesetz erlassen das den
geschäftsbanken die macht geld zu
schaffen nahm und sie wieder dem start
übertrug seitdem wurde alles
digitalisiert was wir jetzt als geld
verwenden sind digitale zahlen die die
geschäftsbanken aus dem nichts
erschaffen
das problem war dass sie in dieser
gesetzgebung die sichteinlagen nicht
berücksichtigt haben einlagen einzelner
kunden bei den banken oder elektronische
formen von geld fast sichteinlagen heute
vorwiegend sind der großteil des geldes
in umlauf heute ist elektronisches geld
es sind sichteinlagen die auf unseren
konten liegen die gesetzgebung muss mit
den entwicklungen des elektronischen
geldes schritt halten und mit der art
und weise wie banken funktionieren
geld das auf bankkonten gehalten wird
wird als sichteinlagen bezeichnet dies
ist ein buchhalterischer begriff den die
banken verwenden wenn sie kredite
erstellen banken folgen dem gleichen
prozess wenn sie kredite vergeben
alles geld das auf bankkonten gehalten
wird ist ein buchhaltungs eintrag
geschäftsbank geld
die realität ist jetzt dass das meiste
geld weder papier noch münzen sind
sondern digital es sind nur ziffern in
einem computersystem
es ist ihre visa debit karte es ist ihre
ec karte das ist das plastik es in
zahlen in einem computersystem geld wird
von einem computersystem in ein anderes
computersystem verschoben es ist eine
einzige große datenbank und dieses
digitale geld verwenden wir jetzt um
zahlungen zu tätigen
wir verwenden es im alltäglichen
wirtschaften
ich denke viele leute in großbritannien
denken wahrscheinlich dass die regierung
oder die zentralbank die kontrolle über
das meiste im umlauf befindliche geld
hat und neues geld in umlauf bringt aber
das ist nicht der fall es sind
privatbanken die die überwiegende
mehrheit das im umlauf befindlichen
neuen geldes schaffen und auch
entscheiden wie es verteilt wird
die offizielle terminologie für diesen
buchhaltungs eintrag ist geschäftsbank
geld wenn banken kredite an die
öffentlichkeit vergeben schaffen sie
neues geschäftsbank geld wenn ein kunde
einen kredit zurück zeit wird das geld
der geschäftsbank vernichtet die banken
behalten die zinsen als gewinn
es gibt viele missverständnisse darüber
wie banken funktionieren das competence
center hat in einer studie leute befragt
wie sie dachten dass banken
funktionieren rund 30 prozent der
befragten denken wenn sie ihr geld auf
die bank bringen bleibt es da und ist
sicher man kann verstehen warum weil
jedes kind ein sparschwein hat in dem es
geld aufbewahrt in zeiten der not
zerbricht man es nimmt das geld und gibt
es aus viele menschen glauben dass das
selber auch auf das bankwesen zutrifft
ein sicherer ort um ihr geld
aufzubewahren so dass es da ist wenn man
es braucht die restlichen 60 prozent der
befragten gehen davon aus dass ihr geld
das sie auf die bank gebracht haben an
jemand anderen überwiesen wird er sich
leyen will wir haben also einen rentner
der sein ganzes leben lang gespart und
dessen ersparnisse an junge leute die
ein haus kaufen wollen verliehen werden
aber so funktionieren banken nicht
wirklich
es ist einfach ein buchhaltungs trick
banken erschaffen geld sie verleihen das
nicht wenn eine bank ein darlehen
vergibt tut sie einfach so als ob
derjenige das geld eingezahlt hätte sie
muss eine zahlungs verbindlichkeit
erfinden so wird die geldmenge
geschaffen professor richard werner
derzeit liegen in großbritannien
geldschöpfung und kontrolle vor allem in
den händen der privaten banken etwa 97
bis 98 prozent des geldes das erschaffen
wird könnte als bank schuldgeld
bezeichnet werden banken bringen geld im
grunde als darlehen in umlauf das wird
häufig nicht verstanden
es ist keine verschwörungstheorie es ist
keine schnapsidee es ist für die bank
von england den prozess selbst
beschreibt wenn banken kredite vergeben
erschaffen sie neues geld
die bei weitem größte rolle bei der
schaffung von geld spielt der
bankensektor wenn banken kredite
vergeben schaffen sie zusätzliche
einlagen für die die sich das geld
leihen paul tucker vizepräsident der
bank of england
einige wenige ökonomen verstehen wie das
geldsystem funktioniert falls man aber
nicht versteht wie das geldsystem
funktioniert dann denkbar dass es gut
für die wirtschaft ist wenn alle sparen
was wirklich passiert vorausgesetzt man
versteht wie das geldsystem funktioniert
wenn jeder anfängt geld zu sparen ist
dass die geldmenge im umlauf schrumpft
was zu einer rezession führt die meisten
ökonomen haben also nicht das gesamtbild
im blick sie verstehen nicht alle teile
des systems sie verlassen sich auf
annahmen allgemein akzeptierte ansichten
ohne wirklich ins detail zu gehen geld
ist ein zentraler aspekt der wirtschaft
wenn jemand nicht versteht woher es
kommt wer es kreiert und wie es kreiert
wird wie kann so jemand die wirtschaft
als ganzes verstehen
wenn die überwiegende mehrheit des
geldes in umlauf nicht bargeld sondern
elektronisches geld ist dann bekommt der
der das elektronische geld schafft auch
den erlös aus dieser geldschöpfung die
erschaffung elektronischen geldes ist
selbstredend viel profitabler als die
herstellung von bargeld da dabei
keinerlei herstellungskosten anfallen
während wir im laufe eines jahrzehntes
durch die herstellung von bargeld 18
milliarden pfund gewinn gemacht haben
haben die banken 1,2 billionen pfund
geschaffen
zwischen 1998 und 2007 verdreifachte
sich die britische geldmenge
1,2 millionen pfund wurden von banken
geschaffen während 18 milliarden pfund
vom finanzministerium geschaffen wurden
wenn ich oder wir oder positiv money so
etwas sagen denken die leute wie er
seien schlichtweg verrückt aber am 9
märz 2009 gab ben bernanke der präsident
der amerikanischen zentralbank das erste
interview das je von einem präsidenten
der amerikanischen zentralbank
ausgestrahlt wurde am tag zuvor hatte er
nie was noch nicht mal eine bank sondern
eine versicherungsgesellschaft ist mit
rund 160 milliarden dollar aus der
patsche geholfen der journalist fragte
ihn nun herr bernanke wo haben sie denn
die 160 milliarden dollar zur rettung
von aig eigentlich her bekommen
ist das steuergeld dass die fed ausgibt
das sind keine steuergelder die banken
haben konnten bei der fed ganz ähnlich
wie sie ein konto in einer geschäftsbank
haben um an eine bank zu leihen müssen
wir die größe des kontos dass sie bei
der fed unterhält im computer
dementsprechend nach oben verändern es
ist also dem gelddrucken viel ähnlicher
als der aufnahme eines kredits auch wenn
es nicht dasselbe ist
banken erschaffen neues geld wenn sie
kredite vergeben
bestehende vermögenswerte kaufen oder
investitionen auf eigene rechnung machen
was meist die erweiterung ihrer
vermögenswerte beinhaltet
wenn eine bank wertpapiere wie
unternehmens- und staatsanleihen kauft
rechnet sie die anleihen zu ihren
vermögenswerten hinzu und vergrößert die
bankeinlagen des unternehmens um die
entsprechende summe neues geschäftsbank
geld kommt den umlauf wenn leute ihre
bankkredite ausgeben
als ich von august 2009 bis zu den
wahlen also in etwa acht neun monaten an
türen geklopft und versucht habe den
menschen zu erklären wie das
finanzsystem funktioniert stößt man auf
eine beinahe immanente weigerung der
menschen zu akzeptieren dass es eine
solch bizarre situation überhaupt geben
kann nein das kann doch nicht sein was
sagen sie da banken können doch nicht
geld aus dem nichts schaffen das ist
lächerlich das dürfen die nicht die
verleihen doch die einlagen ihrer kunden
die meisten menschen haben eine
vorstellung davon was geld ist sie sind
ihren eigenen umgang mit geld gewohnt
und sie versuchen ihre erfahrung damit
wie ihr kleiner haushalt wirtschaftet
auf die nationale wirtschaft zu
übertragen und natürlich klappt das
überhaupt nicht
bis 2008 belief sich das ausstehende
kreditportfolio der von der bank
geschaffenen kredite auch bekannt als
geschäftsbank geld auf über zwei
billionen pfund
noch 1982 betrug das verhältnis von
banknoten und münzen zu bankeinlagen
eins zu zwölf bis 2010 stieg das
verhältnis auf 137 das heißt für jedes
pfund das vom finanzministerium
geschaffenen geldes gab es 37 punkt von
der bank geschaffenes geld
in den zehn jahren vor der krise von
2007 wuchs die geldmenge der britischen
geschäftsbanken jedes jahr um sieben bis
zehn prozent eine wachstumsrate von 7
prozent entspricht einer verdoppelung
der geldmenge alle zehn jahre
die menge an geld die sie aus dem nichts
erschaffen ist einfach unglaublich 1,2
billionen in den letzten zehn jahren das
geld wird entsprechend der prioritäten
des bankensektors verteilt nicht
entsprechend der prioritäten der
gesellschaft
der bankensektor selbst wuchs von 1980
um 25 millionen us dollar auf 40
billionen us-dollar nach vermögenswerten
1980 war das globale bankvermögen 20 mal
so hoch wie die damalige wirtschaft bis
2006 waren sie nach angaben der
vereinten nationen 75 mal so viel wert
wie die folgende grafik zeigt bleiben
die gesamten bank aktiver der britischen
banken als prozentsatz des bip bis ende
der 1960 er jahre relativ stabil bei 50
bis 60 prozent danach schossen sie
dramatisch in die höhe
richtig geld verdienen tut man in der
heutigen welt nicht indem man
irgendetwas herstellt sondern durch
verschiedene formen der spekulation im
grunde geld aus geld machen das ist bei
weitem die lukrativste und weit
verbreitete form der wirtschaftlichen
aktivität die es heute in der welt gibt
heute sind banken nicht mehr daran
gebunden wie viel sie verleihen können
und wie vielen neuen kredit sie aus dem
nichts schaffen können sie sind allein
durch ihre eigene kredit bereitschaft
eingeschränkt
es gibt zwei wesentliche probleme dabei
dass banken geld erschaffen erstens die
tatsache dass sie geld erschaffen indem
sie darlehen vergeben das garantiert
dass wir uns alles geld für die
wirtschaft von den banken leihen müssen
also muss die regierung um eine gesunde
wachsende wirtschaft zu gewährleisten
strategien entwickeln die ständig
wachsende schulden ermöglicht
die regierung kann nur zusätzliche
kaufkraft schaffen indem sie sich selbst
und uns immer mehr verschuldet
das zweite große problem banken geld da
schaffen zu lassen besteht darin dass
sie einen anreiz haben immer mehr zu
erschaffen sie schaffen mehr geld wenn
sie einen kredit vergeben sie bekommen
die boni die kommissionen und somit
anreize so viel wie möglich zu verleihen
da muss man eine verkaufs kultur
entwickeln und was haben sie gemacht sie
haben einen erstaunlichen kerl
angestellt einen sehr netten mann namens
andy hornby der kam von ace de um die
bank in eine art supermarkt zu
verwandeln wenn sie den banken die
geldversorgung anvertrauen wird die
geldmenge unaufhörlich wachsen und somit
die höhe der verschuldung bis zu dem
punkt an dem alles zusammenbricht sobald
manche leute ihre schulden nicht mehr
bedienen können hören sie auf kredite zu
vergeben
man hört politiker und journalisten
sagen dass wir über unsere verhältnisse
gelebt haben wir sind von schulden
abhängig geworden wir müssen unsere
ausgaben kürzen und im rahmen unserer
möglichkeiten leben das ist im jetzigen
system nicht möglich der grund dass alle
so verschuldet sind ist nicht dass sie
sich so leichtsinnig geld geliehen haben
wir haben uns all das geld nicht von
einem heer rentnern geliehen die ihr
ganzes leben gespart haben geld im
derzeitigen system ist schuld es wird
erschaffen wenn banken kredite vergeben
der einzige weg im derzeitigen system
geld in umlauf zu haben und mit dem
unternehmen handeln innen ist denn wie
es bei den banken leihen
das ist das genaue gegenteil von dem was
die konservative partei heute behauptet
dass man nämlich erst einsparungen
machen muss bevor man dem
gesundheitssystem helfen kann und weil
ökonomen diese dinge durcheinander
gebracht haben sowohl in der geldpolitik
als auch im ökonomischen denkens und
weil leute sich immer noch an die
altmodische sichtweise klammern dass man
zunächst sparen muss bevor man
investieren kann stecken wir überhaupt
in dem chaos das wir heute haben
einer der gründe warum wir uns so
schwertun das bankensystem und die
kreditschöpfung zu verstehen ist dass
wir die schule verlassen und kein geld
haben dann fangen wir als klempner
lehrlinge die arbeiten den ganzen monat
hart und am ende des monats deponiert
jemand geld in unserer bank deshalb
haben wir folgende logik man arbeitet
und dann bekommt man geld spart was an
in wirklichkeit hätte man diesen job nie
gekriegt wenn nicht zunächst einmal
einen kredit vergeben worden wäre es ist
ein sehr wichtiges begriffliches
missverständnis nicht nur die
öffentlichkeit hat sich dessen schuldig
gemacht ökonomen verstehen die sache
auch nicht
entsteht nicht durch wirtschaftliche
aktivitäten viele leute denen ich
begegne gehen davon aus dass aus diesem
prozess von unternehmen und menschen
machen was irgendwie geld entsteht aus
dem prozess dass menschen was machen
herstellen an bauern verkaufen
produzieren das geld dabei einfach
irgendwie entsteht es ist aber wie das
öl im auto man muss es hinein tun
wenn ich david cameron sagen höre dass
wir eine wirtschaft brauchen die nicht
auf schulden aufgebaut sondern eine
wirtschaft die auf ersparnissen beruht
dann weiß einfach nicht was er da sagt
es ist lächerlich es ist absolut absurd
um zeigt dass er keinerlei ahnung hat
wie das geldsystem wirklich funktioniert
was er eigentlich sagt ist dass wir eine
wirtschaft ohne geld brauchen
wenn alle sparen würden würde das geld
verschwinden das ist das was eine banken
abschreibung im wesentlichen ist leute
können ihre schulden nicht mehr bedienen
was nichts anderes ist als geld das
verschwindet das die leute aber keine
schulden aufnehmen sollen kann nur ein
scherz sein dass es so eine amateurhafte
auffassung davon wie unsere wirtschaft
und unser geldsystem funktioniert und
wie geld überhaupt erschaffen wird ich
amüsiere mich darüber was die leute so
von sich geben sie plappern einfach nach
was sie voneinander gelernt haben und
sagen immer das gleiche es geht mir
wirklich auf die nerven wenn ich leute
sagen höre wir brauchen mehr
vorschriften wir müssen die bank mehr
regulieren die boni das ist alles nur
ein ablenkungsmanöver weg von den
symptomen einer größeren krankheit sie
müssen sich das geldsystem ansehen und
wie geld erschaffen wird wenn wir keine
schulden mehr wollen dann sagen wir im
grunde dass wir kein geld mehr wollen
dass wir eine geldlose wirtschaft wollen
mit ausnahme der drei prozent die
schuldenfrei erschaffen werden
das ist ein paradox im gegenwärtigen
system wenn wir die öffentlichkeit
weitere schulden machen dann fließt mehr
geld in die wirtschaft und es gibt einen
aufschwung es wird leichter darlehen
aufzunehmen und die leute verschulden
sich weiter der zyklus setzt sich fort
es wird immer leichter sich zu
verschulden dass einige leute
überschuldet sind sie können die
schulden nicht mehr bedienen ihre
hypothek nicht zurückzahlen das ist
zuerst bei den sogenannten subprime
hypotheken in amerika passiert das
verursachte eine welle von
zahlungsunfähigkeiten die sich auf die
gesamte wirtschaft ausdehnt banken
werden zahlungsunfähig ab da befinden
wir uns in einer finanzkrise und die
banken vergäben auf einmal keine kredite
mehr im aufschwung haben sie noch
übermäßig kredite vergeben jetzt
vergeben sie keine kredite mehr was die
rezession noch verschlimmert menschen
verlieren ihre arbeit und werden noch
abhängiger von schulden einfach um zu
überleben wir haben ein system in dem
wir schulden aufnehmen müssen um
überhaupt eine wirtschaft zu haben wir
müssen schulden bei den banken machen
und das garantiert gewaltige gewinne für
die banken
ist das auf und ab des konjunkturzyklus
und ich habe schon früher gesagt keine
rückkehr zu boom und bust
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die netto kreditvergabe der banken muss
für immer steigen
die zahlen lesen auf jedes einzelne
pfund selbst wenn du denkst dass das
geld dir gehört zahlt jemand irgendwo
zinsen auf dieses geld
in das bankensystem hat so einen großen
einfluss auf die welt aber nur weil es
unsere nation mit geld versorgt wir
müssen es schützen wir müssen es
subventionieren wir müssen ihnen
erlauben weiterzumachen weil die
katastrophe eines bankenzusammenbruchs
uns alle enorm betrifft jeder der sagt
wir hätten die bank nicht retten sollen
der versteht das wesen unseres
geldsystems nicht das wäre wie eine
große menge unseres geldes einfach zu
vernichten andererseits erhält die
rettung der banken ein system aufrecht
das sowieso nie funktionieren wird egal
was wir tun wir werden immer diesen
zyklus haben bis wir die geldbeschaffung
von banken trennen dann können die
banken machen was sie wollen sie wären
ein normales unternehmen wie jedes
andere auch
es gibt dabei auch einen wichtigen
demokratischen aspekt private
gewinnorientierte banken ja schaffen bis
zu 200 milliarden im jahr und pumpen es
in die wirtschaft wie es ihnen beliebt
egal ob sie es in toxische derivate
pumpen oder in immobilienblasen wodurch
einfach nur die wohnungen teurer werden
200 milliarden forint flossen im jahr
2007 in die wirtschaft erschaffen aus
dem nichts ein was dieses geld
investiert wird bestimmt die ausrichtung
unserer wirtschaft wenn wir also
jemandem schon erlauben geld aus dem
nichts zu erschaffen
sollten wir zumindest die demokratische
kontrolle darüber haben wofür das geld
ausgegeben wird wollen wir das geld
lieber in das gesundheitswesen
investieren oder um etwas für den
umweltschutz zu tun oder die armut zu
mindern oder wollen wir es eher dafür
ausgeben um häuser teurer zu machen so
dass es sich keiner mehr leisten kann in
einem haus zu wohnen
ms
man kann es als eine super subvention
für banken verstehen für das recht geld
zu schaffen es sollte eigentlich der
allgemeinheit dienen und demokratisch
ausgegeben werden
zentralbank reservewährung
es gibt noch eine weitere art von geld
sozusagen elektronisches bargeld es ist
eine geld form die geschäftsbanken
gebrauchen um untereinander zahlungen
durchzuführen banken wollen keine
riesigen mengen geld herum tragen weil
es gefährlich unbequem und teuer ist für
solche geldmengen muss man einen
sicherheitsdienst anheuern deswegen
bezahlen sie sich gegenseitig mit einer
elektronischen form von bargeld in der
branche bekannt als zentralbankreserven
dieses elektronische bargeld liegt auf
konten bei der bank of england als
einfacher bürger hat man keinen zugriff
auf dieses elektronische geld
man kann bei der bank of england kein
konto eröffnen sie verkaufen dieses
zentralbank geld an die banken sie
schaffen es aus dem nichts und damit
kaufen sie anleihen von den
geschäftsbanken dieser anleihe bei der
sicherung staatsschulden handelt löst
die geschäftsbank bei der bank of
england ein im gegenzug tipp die bank of
england ein paar neue ziffern in das
konto der bank bei der bank of england
im endeffekt erschaffen sie
zentralbankreserven aus dem nichts
die bank of england scharf
zentralbankreserven indem sie das
verfügbare guthaben auf dem konto der
vergleichs bank bei der bank of england
erhöht die abwicklungsbank hinterlegt im
gegenzug anleihen oder verkauft
vermögenswerte als sicherheiten für die
reserven
insgesamt halten 46 banken central
reserve counts bei der bank of england
kleinere oder ausländische banken
unterhalten konnten bei einer dieser 46
banken damit die zahlungen in pfund
sterling annehmen oder tätigen können
vom märz 2009 fragte die bank of england
jeder der großen abwicklungsbanken
wieviel reservewährung sie benötigt die
abwicklungsbanken würden dann eine
anleihe gegen die reserve währung
tauschen und zu stimmen die anleihe für
einen bestimmten betrag zu einem
bestimmten zukünftigen zeitpunkt
zurückzukaufen
die abwicklungsbanken würden dann zinsen
zum basis oder leitzinssatz für die von
ihnen gehaltenen zentralbankreserven
erhalten
seit der krise sind die
zentralbankreserven der
abwicklungsbanken dramatisch in die höhe
geschossen
bedeutung der zentralbankreserven
wenn bankkunden geld von ihrem konto auf
das konto einer anderen person
überweisen findet ein prozess namens
intraday clearing statt der betrag der
zentralen reservewährung den banker bei
der bank of england hat wird um den
entsprechenden betrag reduziert den bank
b erhält
dies ist die bedeutung der zentralbank
währung für die banken
wenn vor der kreditkrise eine bank bei
der bank of england keine zentralen
reserven hatte um ihren verpflichtungen
nachzukommen musste sich die
bankreserven von anderen banken mit
zinsen leihen
es wird nur die reservewährung der
zentralbank bewegt geschäftsbank geld
wird einfach abgezogen und hinzugefügt
wenn sie etwas bei ebay verkaufen wissen
sie dass das geschäft nicht
abgeschlossen ist bis das geld auf ihrem
konto ist die meisten menschen wollen
das geld auf ihrem konto sehen bevor sie
das geschäft abschließen die banken sind
auch nicht anders sie wollen ihr geld
auf ihrem konto bei der bank of england
sehen bevor sie ein geschäft als
abgeschlossen betrachten wenn sie ein
haus von jemandem kaufen der bei einer
anderen bank ist als sie dann
beauftragen sie und nachdem sie 250.000
für ein haus ausgegeben haben jede bank
damit geld an die bank des verkäufers zu
überweisen die bank wiederum weist die
bank of england an 250.000 aus deren
konto bei der bank of england auf das
konto der bank des verkäufers zu
verschieben
dieses geld bewegt sich tatsächlich von
einem zum anderen konto bei der bank of
england wenn sich das geld bewegt hat
dann erst gehen die banken davon aus
dass diese zahlung getätigt wurde sie
handeln nicht wirklich in der art von
geld die wir in unseren konten haben sie
handeln in dieser speziellen währung die
nur bei der zentralbank genutzt werden
kann
es gibt millionen von menschen im ganzen
land die sich alle gegenseitig geld
überweisen indem sie nur wenige große
banken diese banken können eine
strichliste auf ihren computer systemen
führen und in der regel heben sich viele
der bewegungen am ende des tages
gegenseitig auf die fünf großbanken hsbc
barclays und santander halten über 85
prozent aller einlagen
da es eine begrenzte anzahl von banken
im system gibt kann das zentralbankgeld
nur in einem geschlossenen kreislauf um
sie herum bewegt werden das geld
zirkuliert immer und immer wieder durch
dieses system und wenn man darüber
nachdenkt könnte eine ein pfund münze
verwendet werden um eine milliarde pfund
an zahlungen zu leisten wenn sie eine
milliarde mal in umlauf gebracht würde
und das ist das system das sie jetzt
haben sie haben einen kleinen pool von
echtem geld der nur um das system herum
geht und es wird verwendet um eine große
menge an zahlungen in unserem namen zu
tätigen kurz vor der krise befanden sich
nur 20 milliarden pfund auf den konten
der zentralbank
er will sie nicht genug von diesen
zentralbankgeld haben dann können sie
effektiv keine zahlungen leisten und
wenn das passiert dann zerbricht
ziemlich schnell das ganze system die
bank of england hat also die
verantwortung sicherzustellen dass genug
von diesem geld im system ist
die anforderungen an banken eine
bestimmte menge an reserven zu halten
haben sich seit 1947 viele male geändert
zu dieser zeit mussten die banken ein
mindest verhältnis von 32 prozent der
reserven bargeld oder staatsanleihen zu
einlagen einhalten im jahr 2006 wurde
das korridor system eingeführt bei dem
die banken jeden monat ihre eigenen
reserve ziele festlegen konnten
[Musik]
die regeln änderte sich erneut im märz
2009 als die bank of england die
quantitative lockerung einführte die
quantitative lockerung gibt den
abwicklungsbanken die zentrale
reservewährung kostenlos
die zentralbank währung ist das was im
mindestreserve modell als echtes geld
bezeichnet wird aber tatsache ist dass
die banken so viel davon haben können
wie sie wollen und die zentralbank
währung selbst ist eine form von fiat
geld das durch nichts gedeckt ist
infolgedessen gibt es keine sinnvolle
mindestreserve mehr
eine kurze geschichte des geldes
wenn sie sich die geschichte der letzten
150 jahre anschauen dann fängt es mit
der entwicklung des goldstandards an der
in den 1880 und 1890 er jahren ins
blickfeld gerät dabei koppeln sich
länder an einen bestimmten gold wert
schaffen ein abkommen diesen wert
beizubehalten und gold untereinander zu
handeln um sicherzustellen dass die
balance stimmt außerdem um zu versuchen
die aktivitäten der eigenen wirtschaft
einzuschränken oder zu erweitern um
sicherzustellen dass das gleichgewicht
zu diesem fixpreis beibehalten wird ist
das alles bricht nach dem ersten
weltkrieg zusammen das ganze bricht
auseinander eine massive verlagerung im
internationalen währungssystem die nicht
wirklich gelöst wird bis zum abkommen
von bretton woods in dem alles an den
dollar und der dollar an gold gekoppelt
wird
also ein schritt entfernt von einer
golddeckung oder zu einer art von
solidem waren geld hinter den papieren
kreditgeld dass wir alle nutzen
sozusagen einen schritt davon entfernt
roscheba fragte sich tokio waren die
nächste atombombe fallen würde das haben
sie nicht lange gefragt
[Musik]
1944 in bretton woods haben die usa und
großbritannien begonnen zu verhandeln
wie sie die weltwirtschaft und das
globale währungssystem regieren könnten
dabei haben sie die weltbank den iwf und
noch ein paar andere institutionen
entworfen um die globalen währungen zu
regulieren und es gab noch einen gold
standard aber dieser goldstandard war an
den dollar gebunden alles gold der welt
zog von london nach fort knox und
sämtliche währungen der welt waren an
den dollar gebunden dieses system wurde
entwickelt um mögliche ungleichgewichte
zu managen und um kreditknappheit zu
verhindern bei staaten handelt es sich
bei kreditknappheit um ein
handelsdefizit sie können ihre
rechnungen nicht mehr bezahlen und die
währung bricht ein die währungen wurden
verwaltet und das system war stabil
solange die amerikaner die rolle des
aufpasser spielten
wer weiß wie die geschichte ausging
die menge an geld also die nötig war um
den vietnamkrieg zu bezahlen genau
darauf wollte ich ihn aus öl
preisschocks waren ein weiterer fall die
amerikaner respektierten ihre rolle des
währungssystems zu verwalten nicht mehr
sie haben den wert ihrer eigenen währung
aufgeblasen die eigentlich gekoppelt
sein sollte gekoppelt an gold wie jeder
andere währung was haben die franzosen
da unternommen die franzosen waren ein
wenig sorge dass präsident nixon nicht
ganz ehrlich war sie waren besorgt
darüber dass nächsten geld druckt obwohl
er das nicht sollte und sie waren
besorgt dass es nicht genug gold gab den
wechselkurs des französischen frau
einzulösen also schickten sie ein
kriegsschiff in den hafen von new york
um ausgesprochen freundlich zu fragen ob
sie nicht bitte ihr gold zurück haben
könnten
haben sie ihr geld zurückbekommen haben
sie nicht und das bretton-woods-system
fand sein ende an diesem punkt betreten
wir die moderne ära des finanzsystems
fehlt geld ein tauschmittel dass der
emittent nicht verspricht in einer ware
einzulösen und das auf vertrauen basiert
historisch gesehen war die geldschöpfung
an eine wahre gebunden oft an gold aber
heute ist sie an nichts gebunden
das bedeutet dass es nichts gibt was
unser geld absichert dieses stück papier
ist nur ein stück papier was bleibt uns
wenn geld auf nichts passiert warum
glauben wir dass es überhaupt einen wert
hat
wie es immer noch umtauschen können
das wort kredit kommt aus dem
lateinischen und steht für glauben
glauben
seit dem zusammenbruch des dollar
goldstandards im jahr 1971 und der
deregulierung des finanzsystems ist die
geldschöpfung exponentiell gewachsen
das world economic forum das sich in
davos trifft hat sich zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt auf die notwendigkeit geeinigt
den kreditrahmen der weltwirtschaft um
100 millionen us dollar zu erweitern
eine million hat zwölf nullen 100
millionen ist eine eins gefolgt von 14 0
sie glauben dass diese kreditexpansion
an den boom auslösen wird weil es jetzt
mehr geld in der wirtschaft gibt mit dem
investitionen getätigt werden können
es ist faszinierend diese entstehung der
digitalen währungen wie sie wirklich
alles verändert hat weil es privatbanken
völlig entfesselt hat das geldsystem zu
dominieren und so zu gestalten dass es
für sie arbeitet und für die leute die
privatbanken leiten
wachstum und inflation wenn sie bei der
derzeitigen konstellation eine wachsende
wirtschaft haben wollen dann bedeutet
das auch wachsende schulden das ist
etwas das nur sehr sehr wenige menschen
verstehen vor allem aber keine politiker
die wiederum die wirtschaft managen was
ein beängstigender gedanke ist
bruttoinlandsprodukt der markt wird
aller in einem land in einem bestimmten
zeitraum produzierten end produkte und
dienstleistungen
wenn die geldmenge wächst steht mehr
geld zur verfügung das in produktive
wege investiert werden kann es kann
jedoch auch verwendet werden um damit zu
spielen und die vermögenspreise in die
höhe zu treiben
eine erhöhung der geldmenge ein
wahrscheinlicher relative anstieg der
wirtschaftstätigkeit
die auswirkungen einer raschen
kreditexpansion
inflation ist ein anstieg des
allgemeinen niveaus der preise für waren
und dienstleistungen in einer
volkswirtschaft über einen bestimmten
zeitraum
wenn das allgemeine preisniveau steigt
kauft jede währungseinheit weniger waren
und dienstleistungen
wenn die geldmenge wächst und mehr
währung zur verfügung steht steht mehr
geld für investitionen zur verfügung was
zu wachstum führen kann aber es steht
auch mehr geld für den kauf von waren
und spekulationen zur verfügung was zu
inflation führt
[Musik]
im wesentlichen ist inflation das was
passiert wenn zu viel geld zu wenigen
gütern und dienstleistungen nach jagd so
dass es zu viel geld für die
tatsächliche produktion der wirtschaft
gibt
in den sieben jahren zwischen 2000 und
2007 hat sich die geldmenge verdoppelt
und die bank of england hatte den
eindruck es unter kontrolle zu haben
weil sie sich dort sagten dass die
preise nicht so stark stiegen sie haben
aber nur die preise in den tante emma
läden vor ort berücksichtigt
immobilienpreise haben sie nicht
berücksichtigt obwohl immobilien die
größte ausgabe sind die die meisten
menschen tätigen
viele westliche länder subventionieren
stark die landwirtschaftliche produktion
was dazu führt dass preise und inflation
niedrig gehalten werden
steigende häuserpreise können ihnen
vielleicht das gefühl geben dass sie
reicher sind aber dass sich ihr vermögen
vergrößert hat den effekt dass das
vermögen ihrer kinder abnimmt es
entsteht also keinen nettogewinn
vermögen denn ihre kinder müssen
tatsächlich um so mehr zahlen wenn sie
ein haus kaufen wollen es entsteht also
keine netto wertsteigerung sie werden
noch mehr verdienen müssen sie müssen
noch mehr schulden aufnehmen
steigende hauspreise schaffen also
keinen zusätzlichen bip wert für die
wirtschaft was sie tun ist reichtum an
diejenigen leute zu verteilen die
bereits häuser haben dh die reicheren
menschen und nehmen es ärmeren menschen
die es sich nicht leisten können auf dem
eigenheim markt mitzumischen zuzulassen
dass sich immobilienpreise aufblähen ist
ein weiteres beispiel für eine äußerst
aggressive politik dadurch hat zwar
jeder irgendwie das gefühl die dinge
laufen ganz gut und leute geben mehr
geld für andere dinge aus indem sie ihre
immobilien seien aber es schafft keine
neuen arbeitsplätze es verbessert die
qualität unserer wirtschaft nicht es
hilft unsere handelsbilanz nicht es
verringert das haushaltsdefizit nicht es
ist ein nullsummenspiel
august 2011 waren 85 1 prozent der
bankkredite von verbrauchern als
hypotheken auf wohnungen besichert
wenn sie jemanden haben der welt
erschafft das nur für eine sache
ausgegeben werden kann nämlich das
wohnen dann wird der preis für dieses
ding steigen zwischen 2000 und 2010
schufen sie über eine billion pfund
neues geld 500 milliarden pfund allein
in den drei jahren vor der krise deshalb
stiegen die hauspreise so stark die
häuser selbst tragen nicht besonders es
war einfach all das geld das in diesem
markt gepumpt wurde
wenn geld in die wirtschaft fließt dann
geht viel geld in immobilien hypotheken
zum beispiel das ist eine steigerung der
geldmenge in der wirtschaft ohne eine
entsprechende steigerung an aktivität
leistung oder bps sind ausgaben die das
bip nicht beeinflussen das verursachte
inflation in großbritannien hatten wir
es im überfluss
wir hatten diesen massiven
immobilienboom die hauptursache für den
immobilienboom meiner meinung nach ist
die riesige menge an von banken
geschaffen spekulativen krediten die in
immobilien flossen wenn häuser billiger
wäre wären sie einfacher zu bauen mehr
davon würden gebaut werden es gebe
weniger riesige häuser mit kaum menschen
in london wäre nicht das zentrum einer
opulenten spekulativen orgie wo alle
reichen menschen auf der welt eigentum
besitzen wollen weil es für eine gute
anlage gehalten wird
wir wären in erster linie ordner in
denen man wohnt nicht in die man
investiert es ist wichtig zu bedenken
dass sie während sie eine bank optionen
haben wenn sie einen kredit vergeben
wenn sie den kredit an ein kleines
unternehmen vergeben wissen sie um die
relativ hohe wahrscheinlichkeit dass der
kredit nicht zurückgezahlt wird da die
eigentümer des kleinen unternehmens eine
beschränkte haftung haben denn das
unternehmen pleite geht kriegen sie als
bank nicht zurück das ist ein ziemlich
hohes risiko verglichen damit ist
jemandem zu leihen der eine sicherheit
bietet wie ein haus wie eine hypothek
es gibt also einen einfachen anreiz für
banken mehr geld er in immobilien als in
kleine unternehmen zu stecken das wird
zu einem echten problem wenn sie das auf
die ganze wirtschaft übertragen denn
dadurch gibt es einen anreiz geld er in
spekulative als in produktive
investitionen zu stecken
wir müssen uns also überlegen wie wir
ein geldsystem schaffen dass spekulative
und produktive investitionen besser in
einklang bringt die regierung zeigt
äußerst wenig bereitschaft den
wohnungsmarkt zu regulieren und die
menge an geld zu regulieren dass banken
in immobilien stecken
wir entscheiden nicht wer und wofür
kredite vergeben werden wir überlassen
diese entscheidung im prinzip ein paar
typen in einer bank
eine kurze geschichte der blasen
eine blase entsteht bei sehr hoher
inflation des preises einer bestimmten
ware oder dienstleistung innerhalb
kurzer zeit
die erste aufgezeichnete blase war die
tulpen blase von 1637 die bedeutung der
sache mit den tulpen ist dass wir hier
die erste finanzblase und deren crash
überhaupt haben die begeisterung für
tulpen schwarze tulpen galten als ein
mystisches ideal dafür was jemand durch
kultivierung über viele generationen
genetisch manipulieren konnte wurde in
den 1600 30er jahren zu einer man in den
niederlanden ihnen war nicht bewusst
dass viele der muster gar nicht
genetisch waren sondern durch einen
virus verursacht wurden aber sie
handelten damit so lange bis eine
tulpenzwiebel das zehnfache dessen wert
war was ein mensch damals in den
niederlanden im jahr im durchschnitt
verdiente ein
futures markt mit tulpenzwiebeln weil
man sie ja jetzt pflanzt ohne zu wissen
was aus dem boden kommen wird also
bereits vor 400 jahren sehen wir dass
ein geldsystem oder ein finanzsystem
nicht ist was da draußen im abstrakten
im etat existiert sondern etwas das mit
starten macht handel und deren
wechselwirkung zu tun hat
im gegensatz zu tulpen die ein
überflüssiges luxusgut sind sind häuser
eine notwendigkeit und ein luxus
zugleich und als solche sind sie ein
ideales vehikel für geld und die
schöpfung einer blase eine behausung ist
vielleicht der wertvollste besitz den
die meisten menschen anstreben
immobilienpreise auf diese art
aufzublasen ermöglicht es einer nation
ihre geldmenge zu vergrößern ohne die
inflationsdaten zu beeinflussen die
dadurch gewonnene zusätzliche kaufkraft
erhöht das wahrgenommene vermögen im
vergleich zu anderen nationen und
schafft dadurch relative macht es ist
ein weg die monetäre macht zu steigern
ohne in das produktive wachstum der
industrie zu investieren
großbritannien und amerika sind
sicherlich herausragende beispiele dafür
dies sind länder mit einem sehr hohen
anteil an privatem hauseigentum es gibt
also eine gute basis um solch eine
politik hinterrücks zu versuchen ich
glaube es war ziemlich offensichtlich im
fall der usa als alan greenspan als chef
der federal reserve ende der 90er mit
einem börsencrash konfrontiert bewusst
die zinssätze auf nahezu null zusammen
drückte jeder kann kredite aufnehmen
günstig es ist besonders leicht ein haus
zu beleihen da es sich um einen
vermögenswert handelt bei dem die bank
sagen kann okay wir leihen ihnen nicht
einfach geld ohne sicherheit sie haben
ja ein haus was toll ist weil wir es in
besitz nehmen können das werden sie
ihnen beim abschluss der hypothek zwar
nicht sagen aber sie könnten das tun und
diese blase ist dann genau das was die
expansion schürt sowie in den usa und
großbritannien wo in den nächsten zehn
jahren etwas ähnliches passiert es ist
auch ein spiegelbild der tieferliegenden
schwäche dieser regierungen ihnen fehlt
einfach der wille und möglicherweise
auch die fähigkeit wobei ich denke dass
es mehr auf den willen ankommt die
finanzmärkte herauszufordern das
großkapital herauszufordern und zu sagen
dass wir jetzt etwas anders machen und
ihr müsst mit ziehen weil wir
demokratisch gewählt worden und ihr nun
mal nicht und wir haben ein mandat dazu
wir werden das jetzt umsetzen
denken sie daran dass alles teil des
plans ist was machst du rom du hast doch
dafür gestimmt
was in den niederlanden passierte zu
einer zeit als sie versuchten von
spanien unabhängig zu werden und genug
geld aufzubringen um eine armee aus zu
heben um sich zu befreien war
finanztechnische innovation sie haben
öffentliche lotterien eingeführt um geld
aufzutreiben
sie hatten eine öffentliche abgaben das
war die idee die zu öffentlichen
beteiligungen führte ein stück vom
kuchen denn dass jeder investieren
konnte das bedeutete dass in den 1600
30er jahren etwa zwei drittel der
bevölkerung in tulpenzwiebeln
investierte nach der unabhängigkeit
wurden diese instrumente zur
finanzierung der expansion angewendet
konnte sich ein so kleines land gegen so
viel größere länder behaupten spanien
und portugal zum beispiel deren imperien
anders als die niederlande bereits seit
über einem jahrhundert bestand hatten
wie konnten sie konkurrieren auf
grundlage welcher ressource sie hatten
ein effizienteres weiterentwickeltes und
breiter angelegt das finanzsystem die
instrumente die sie erfunden haben
erlaubten es ihnen zu jedem zeitpunkt
schneller mehr geld aufzubringen als
jeder andere
unglaublich aber wahr
wie kann inflation vermieden werden
inflation kann vermieden werden wenn die
menge des geldes das in die wirtschaft
fließt reguliert wird so dass sie die
tatsächliche leistung der wirtschaft
nicht übersteigt
meiner meinung nach ist der beste weg
das sicherzustellen geld nur für
produktive investitionen zu schaffen für
produktive güter und dienstleistungen so
fließt geld und den aufbau eines kleinen
unternehmens dass arbeitsplätze schafft
das zusätzliche kaufkraft schafft was
bedeutet dass es keine inflation gibt
fast alle zentralbanken in der
geschichte haben eine form der direkten
kredit regulierung betrieben die
zentralbank bestimmt zunächst das
gewünschte nominale bip wachstum dann
berechnet sie die notwendige menge an
kreditschöpfung um das zu erreichen dann
wird die so geschaffene kreditmenge an
die verschiedenen banken und arten von
banken und die industriellen sektoren
verteilt unproduktiver kredit würde
unterdrückt damit wäre es schwierig oder
gar unmöglich an bankkredite für enorme
rein spekulative transaktionen zu kommen
wie die immensen bankfinanzierungen für
hedgefonds heutzutage die weltbank
erkannte in einer studie aus dem jahr
1993 an dass dieser mechanismus aus
intervention und kredit verteilung im
herzen des ostasiatischen
wirtschaftswunders lag
es gibt alle möglichen dinge die
regierungen in der vergangenheit getan
haben die beispiele die einem sofort
einfallen sind zu korea japan oft in
ostasien wo regierungen darauf
ausgerichtet sind die wirtschaft in ein
gleichgewicht zu bringen sie suchen
sektoren aus und entscheiden wo
investitionen getätigt werden sollten
das muss auch bald in großbritannien
passieren weil wir einen
nachfragebedingten rezession haben und
nicht so sehr eine krise des angebots
sie brauchen ein system in dem kredit in
produktive unternehmungen fließt wo
kredit in den bau eines
hochgeschwindigkeits schienennetzes
gesteckt wird wo kredite zum bau von
häusern zur verfügung stehen anstatt
leuten geld zu geben um den preis der
häuser in die höhe zu treiben es ist
wirklich so einfach das derzeitige
system ist nicht darauf ausgerichtet das
zu tun
die schaffung von geld durch
privatbanken für den nicht produktiven
gebrauch verursachte eine reale
inflation und ist als solcher eine
steuer auf die kaufkraft des
tauschmittel
minderung des lebensstandards
die zahlen für großbritannien sind
ziemlich krass die mittleren
durchschnitt realeinkommen sind für die
meisten menschen in den letzten acht
jahren geschrumpft sie sinken jetzt
gerade stark da wir in die rezession
rutschen die heftigste seit den 1930 er
jahren also sinkt das realeinkommen
von der bank geschaffene viert währung
ermöglicht das den privatbanken reichtum
aus der wirtschaft zu saugen und führt
im laufe der zeit zu einer allmählichen
senkung des lebensstandards
wenn die menschen ärmer werden werden
sie noch abhängiger von schulden und
dies zu einer zeit in der sich effizienz
und mechanisierung dramatisch verbessert
haben
in den 1960 er jahren haben wir erwartet
dass ein zeitalter der mooser anbricht
die und fernsehsendungen haben sie
gefragt was die leute mit ihrer freizeit
anstellen und jetzt arbeiten mehr
menschen härter als je zuvor
sie geben mehr geld aus als je zuvor was
natürlich toll aussieht jeder gibt mehr
geld aus aber wenn man nicht wirklich
was davon hat was man ausgibt wenn sie
ihr geld für kinderbetreuung für das
pendeln zur arbeit und dergleichen
ausgeben müssen kosten die die menschen
früher nicht aufbringen mussten weil sie
zur arbeit laufen konnten ein mitglied
der familie konnte zu hause bleiben und
sich um den haushalt kümmern dann geht
es einem nicht wirklich besser
specials
jeder steht heutzutage unter solch einem
enormen druck ich bin mir bewusst dass
meine vier neffen und nichten schwere
zeiten vor sich haben sie werden sehr
hart arbeiten müssen nur um ein dach
über dem kopf zu behalten um überhaupt
ein zu haben
die menschen werden netto immer ärmer
weil die preise immer weiter steigen
weil dieses ganze spiel geld von den
banken ins system gepumpt wird und sie
erzeugen alle diese schulden zur
gleichen zeit in der die preise steigen
und die dinge immer teurer werden
verschulden wir uns immer mehr und unser
wohlstand und das was wir tatsächlich
für unsere arbeit kriegen wird immer
weniger
sie können nichts gegen armut
unternehmen wenn sie ein finanz und
geldsystem haben das geld von den armen
an die sehr reichen verteilt jeder
versuch einer verteilung in die
entgegengesetzte richtung ist wie gegen
den wind zu pinkeln nehmen sie die
zunehmende ungleichheit eine
offensichtliche möglichkeit ungleichheit
zu bekämpfen ist eine umverteilung durch
steuern sie besteuert die reichen und
geben etwas geld an die arme sie
verschieben ein bisschen geld auf der
skala das ist gut und schön aber wenn
sie völlig übersehen dass es eine
weitere umverteilung gibt die den armen
geld nimmt und es den reichen gibt dann
werden sie die ungleichheit nie in den
griff bekommen
auf schulden basierendes system stellt
sicher dass es für jedes pfund an geld
ein pfund schulden gibt diese schulden
landen am ende bei den armen und der
unteren mittelschicht diese menschen
sitzen am ende auf den schuldenbergen
und zahlen zinsen auf das geld das vlies
dann zurück in den bankensektor und wird
unter den leuten verteilte intercity
oder an der wallstreet arbeiten
insgesamt gesehen verteilt das system
geld von den ärmeren an die reichen
verteilt geld aus den ärmeren regionen
großbritanniens zurück an die city of
london
und es verteilt geld von den kleinen
betrieben den kleinen fabriken in ganz
großbritannien zurück an den
finanzsektor
wir haben ein system bei dem die
aktivität tatsächlich unter dem gleichen
dach stattfindet wie die gleiche
organisation die dafür verantwortlich
ist von der zusammenstellung von
kreditnehmern und kreditgebern das heißt
einer bank zu profitieren eine bank
schafft also die geldmenge unserer
nation und vergibt kredite für den
profit
die regierung kann nicht zulassen dass
das bankensystem zusammenbricht denn
wenn sie es täten würden über 97 prozent
des gesamten geldes verschwinden deshalb
wird im krisenfall das risiko auf den
steuerzahler übertragen aber auch in
normalen zeiten erhalten banken
zahlreiche garantien und vorteile die
über das recht auf geldschöpfung
hinausgehen
ich weiß übrigens dass die bank of
america eine sehr große bank ist
zufällig habe ich selbst 32 dollar dort
liegen welche garantie habe ich dass das
geld auch sicher ist
nun alle einlagen bis zu 10.000 dollar
sind bei der bundesregierung in
washington versichert ist das eine
garantie was hast du gehört dass die
bundesregierung mit 280 milliarden in
den miesen ist
banken erhalten große sicherheitsnetze
von der regierung der steuerzahler
garantiert 85.000 pfund an
einlagensicherheit und die bank of
england bietet liquidität sicherheit für
den fall dass eine bank die
zentralbankreserven ausgehen
jemand schrieb dass eine große
investmentbank wie ein gigantischer
vampir tintenfisch ist der sich um das
antlitz der menschheit geschlungen hat
politiker hypnotisierend die mit geld
nach den banken werfen an keinerlei
bedingungen geknüpft egal was für ein
schaden angerichtet wird den planeten
zerstören kürzungen erzwingen bei dingen
die das leben besser machen
auf wiedersehen schulen auf wiedersehen
spielplätze auf wiedersehen
arbeitsplätze
die banker die wir raus gehauen haben
haben sich im anschluss boni gegönnt die
größer waren als die erste runde der
öffentlichen ausgaben kürzungen
großbritannien allein gab den banken
mehr geld als es kostet einen mann sechs
mal auf den mond zu schießen
[Musik]
annika wo ist unser geld hin wer lässt
den banken das durchgehen
warum können vampir tintenfische jemals
nützlich sein keine regierung ist bisher
mutig genug sie zu zähmen
vielleicht brauchen sie einen plan
die große wende die rückeroberung
unserer banken
immer mehr schulden
die agenda der ausgabenkürzungen ist ein
versuch der regierung schulden von ihrem
konto auf das der öffentlichkeit zu
verlagern das ist die antwort der
regierung auf die bankenrettung und die
es notwendig in einem auf schulden
basierenden geldsystem in dem ein
anstieg der kaufkraft das ergebnis
steigender schulden ist und in dem eine
diversifizierung der schulden allgemeine
stabilität und marktvertrauen herstellt
maßnahmen wie eine erhöhung der
studiengebühren und die privatisierung
öffentlicher dienstleistungen
vermögenswerte und industrie folgen
demselben muster
das problem mit dem wir konfrontiert
sind ist dass es eine übertragung der
öffentlichen schulden auf private
schulden gibt was im wesentlichen eine
verlagerung des risikos ist weg von den
aktiengesellschaften und der regierung
auf die schultern von individuen und es
werden die verwundbarsten individuen
seien die die meiste schuld tragen
werden es ist also kein progressiver
sondern ein repressiver politischer
rahmen dem sich die regierung
verschrieben hat bei dem das risiko auf
die am meisten verwundbaren abgewälzt
wird wenn es einen weiteren finanz shop
gibt einen ölschock zum beispiel dann
werden die ärmsten menschen in der
gesellschaft die strafe zahlen oder
hausbesitzer werden in eine
überschuldung steuern wenn die zinsen
nur ein oder zwei prozent steigen es
wird richtig große probleme geben
deswegen denke ich dass das überhaupt
kein sinnvoller weg nach vorne ist es
ist aggressiv und sicherlich nicht fährt
zu den bedingungen von denen die
regierung spricht und es ist mit
sicherheit auch kein fall von das stehen
wir gemeinsam durch
da immer mehr ressourcen und industrien
des landes privatisiert werden nimmt der
private sektor mehr schulden auf dadurch
wird mehr geld geschaffen und es gibt
einen boom
einige private equity unternehmen haben
diese theorie auf die spitze getrieben
und betreiben eine praxis die als
leveraged buy-out bekannt ist bei der
ein unternehmen zu einem oft überhöhten
preis gekauft wird und der kaufpreis als
schuld an das unternehmen übertragen
wird
[Musik]
das unternehmen wird für die
finanzierung des eigenen kaufs
verantwortlich diese schulden sind oft
so groß dass das unternehmen personal
gehälter und forschungsaktivitäten
reduzieren muss
wenn sie zinsen als unternehmen
berücksichtigen müssen wenn sie die
zinsrückzahlungen in ihre waren und
dienstleistungen
einbeziehen dann müssen sie einen
dauerhaft höheren preis verlangen wenn
sie immer mehr schulden aufnehmen
eine zunahme der diversifizierung der
schulden führt zu einer erhöhung der
geldmenge
wenn die geldmenge steigt steht mehr
geld für produktive aktivitäten und
konsum zur verfügung was die
voraussetzung für einen boom ist
es ist fraglich ob wir diese rezession
überwinden oder ob es so bleibt wie es
jetzt ist falls wir jedoch die rezession
überwinden und die wirtschaft wieder
wächst beobachtet was mit den schulden
passiert die schulden werden ansteigen
und zwar umso schneller je schneller die
wirtschaft wächst in drei bis fünf
jahren werden wir wieder dort sein wo
wir einst waren die schulden werden so
viel und die leute werden ihre kredite
wieder nicht bedienen können es liegt an
dem system in dem wir zur zeit
eingesperrt sind die wirtschaft kann
nicht wachsen ohne dass die schulden
ansteigen und es sind die schulden die
die wirtschaft zusammenbrechen lassen
die einzige option ist die banken daran
zu hindern geld als schulden zu schaffen
indem wir das geldsystem ändern können
wir die banken davon abhalten eine
weitere finanzkrise zu verursachen
außerdem können wir die kürzung der
sozialleistungen die steuererhöhungen
und den anstieg der staatsverschuldung
unnötig machen
das derzeitige system erlaubt dass den
banken geld aus der wirtschaft
abzuschöpfen ohne im gegenzug etwas
produktives zu leisten
warum ist es so dass wir all die
technologie haben diese neue effizienz
und trotzdem braucht es mittlerweile
zwei personen um einen haushalt zu
finanzieren
während das in den 50er jahren nur eine
person brauchte die geld verdiente der
grund dafür ist nicht das waschmaschinen
und alles andere teurer wird es ist
wegen der schulden und weil der
bankensektor bei allen anderen absahnt
ein wachsender bankensektor ist also
nichts gutes wenn der bankensektor
wächst liegt es daran dass er entweder
ineffizienter oder ein parasit für den
rest der wirtschaft wird wenn der
bankensektor 45 6 prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes ausmacht was
passiert mit dem rest der wirtschaft der
verringert sich auf 96 95 94 prozent des
bip wir müssen uns jetzt einmischen wenn
wir irgend eines der anderen großen
sozialen probleme angehen wollen müssen
wir zuerst das geld problem lösen
die ärmsten auf dieser welt zahlen für
krisen auch wenn sie nicht von den oft
rücksichtslosen und höchst spekulativen
booms profitiert haben wie der
immobilienboom in irland der dieser
krise vorausgegangen ist in den letzten
30 jahren haben wir einen anstieg in den
einkommensunterschieden gesehen bei dem
die reichen sehr viel reicher wurden
aber normale menschen nicht sie
verdienen genauso viel oder sind sogar
ärmer geworden ein weg die wirtschaft am
laufen zu halten war diesen menschen
günstige kredite zur verfügung zu
stellen ihnen schulden anzubieten weil
sie sich nichts mehr wirklich leisten
konnten damit sie weiter kaufen wenn es
kollabiert sind es dieselben menschen
die wieder zahlen müssen auch wenn sie
in vielerlei hinsicht schon zuvor die
opfer waren
aufgrund der krise hat die zentralbank
von england firmen schulden aufgekauft
und niedriger verzinst dennoch wird von
der durchschnittlichen person verlangt
mehr denn je zu zahlen um
überziehungskredite und kreditkarten zu
erhalten
schulden zwischen den sehr reichen oder
zwischen regierungen können immer neu
verhandelt werden und so war es schon
immer in der weltgeschichte schulden
sind nicht in stein gemeißelt es ist im
allgemeinen wenn man schulden hat die
die arme den reichen schulden dass diese
plötzlich zu einer heiligen
verpflichtung werden die wichtiger ist
als alles andere die idee schulden neu
zu verhandeln wird plötzlich undenkbar
können sie genau sagen was die
investoren bei laune hält und sie
zuversichtlicher machen würde
das ist schwierig zu sagen persönlich
spielt es keine rolle sehen sie ich bin
ein händler mich interessiert so etwas
nicht wirklich
zahle seine steuern
und aus wenn ich eine chance sehe geld
zu verdienen ergreife ich sie die
meisten von uns händlern interessieren
sich nicht so sehr dafür wie man die
wirtschaft stabilisieren kann unsere
aufgabe ist es damit geld zu verdienen
und ich persönlich träume seit drei
jahren von diesem moment wenn sie wissen
was zu tun ist können sie damit viel
geld verdienen ich muss ein geständnis
ablegen ich gehe jede nacht ins bett ich
träume von einer weiteren rezession
ich träume von einem weiteren moment wie
diesem damit können sie viel geld
verdienen
bruno virginia hat jemandem ganz böse
wehgetan
wenn man sich in europa umschaut und
sieht wie der neue ministerpräsident von
griechenland nicht gewählt sondern
eingesetzt wurde papademos ein
ehemaliger mitarbeiter von goldman sachs
der neue premierminister und
finanzminister italiens mario monti
ehemaliger mitarbeiter von goldman sachs
der neue präsident der europäischen
zentralbank ehemaliger mitarbeiter von
goldman sachs deren leute sind überall
das ist der weg um zu verändern was wir
haben alle macht und alle freiheiten von
den menschen wegzunehmen und alles in
die hände einer kleinen gruppe mit
absoluter macht zu geben
vom volk ohne das volk gegen das volk
was bei all dem interessant war ist die
frage der demokratie die in europa sehr
stark aufgeworfen wurde dass man eine
regierung von bankern hat die einem im
wesentlichen auf gezwungen wurde es sind
banker die uns mehr oder weniger in
diese lage gebracht haben klingt übel
ist aber wahr und dann sagen sie okay
dieselben denker sollen uns jetzt retten
und sie werden jetzt ihr land regieren
das ist eine ernste frage der demokratie
die sich hier auftut
übrigens hat die bankenkrise mehr als
100 millionen menschen zurück in die
armut getrieben
die sterblichkeitsrate von menschen die
in die armut geraten sind steigt aus
einer ganzen reihe von gründen enorm an
bei der bankenkrise ging es also nicht
nur darum ärmer zu werden es ging auch
um die tötung von menschen und wissen
sie was ein ende ist nicht in sicht wir
haben nie jemanden zur rechenschaft
gezogen und wir haben nicht die radikale
reform arbeit geleistet weil wir
fälschlicherweise dachten wenn wir die
situation weiter die stabilisieren würde
es die sache noch schlimmer machen und
raten sie mal wer die entscheidungen
getroffen hat all die leute die vorher
schon da waren
ich denke sie sollten wissen dass das
geschäft eines dieser geschäftsleute
mord ist
ihre waffen sind modern doch ihr denken
2000 jahre alt
sehen sie ich war dabei als der sekretär
und der vorsitzende der federal reserve
in diesen tagen zusammen kamen und mit
mitgliedern des kongresses darüber
sprachen was vor sich ging es war der 15
september
am donnerstag gegen 11 uhr bemerkte die
federal reserve auf einen enormen
rückgang der geldmarkt konnten in den
vereinigten staaten 550 milliarden
dollar wurden in ein oder zwei stunden
herausgezogen
das finanzministerium punkte 105
milliarden dollar in das system und
erkannte schnell dass dieser menge geld
nicht helfen wird wir hatten einen
elektronischen run auf die banken sie
entschieden den betrieb sowie die geld
konnten zu schließen und eine garantie
von 250.000 dollar pro konto
anzukündigen damit es keine weiteren
panik geben wird das ist tatsächlich
passiert
wenn sie das nicht getan hätten wären
wohl bis um zwei uhr an diesem
nachmittag 5,5 millionen dollar aus dem
geldmarkt system der vereinigten staaten
gezogen worden es hätte die gesamte
wirtschaft der vereinigten staaten
zerstört und innerhalb von 24 stunden
wäre die weltwirtschaft
zusammengebrochen
internationale aspekte
und wenn geld international von einer
währung in einer anderen abgehoben wird
verschiebt sich die reservewährung von
der nationalbank eines landes auf das
reserve konto der ausländischen bank
ausländischer banken unterhalten
beziehungen zu lokalen banken die es
ihnen ermöglichen die wiesn währungen zu
halten ohne teil des zentralbank systems
der lokalen zentralbank zu sein
wenn beispielsweise 1000 pfund in euro
überwiesen werden vereinbart eine
britische bank mit einer bank des
euroraums einen wechselkurs die
britische bank überweist dann 1000 pfund
der zentralen reservewährung an die
britische partnerbank der europäischen
bank während die europäische bank
1150 euro reservewährung an die
europäische partner bank der britischen
bank überweist
was passiert wenn währungen und das
wechselkurssystem nicht mehr verwaltet
werden was sind einige der ersten
konsequenzen abwertungen spekulation
ungleichgewichte wo einige länder immer
mehr und mehr von wasser ansammeln
würden
andere währungen
die reservewährung muss im ursprungsland
ausgegeben und in andere währungen
umgetauscht werden
die meisten ausländischen banken
verfügen nicht über einlagen konnten
außerhalb ihrer landesgrenzen und daher
kommen die von ihnen gehaltenen
währungsreserven nicht in form von
einlagen an sie zurück
wenn ein land handelsungleichgewichte
anhäuft akkumuliert es entweder devisen
reservewährungen im falle von
überschüssen oder gibt seine eigenen
reserven im falle negativer
handelsbilanzen aus
die handelsbilanz ist im grunde der
unterschied zwischen dem was sie im
ausland verkaufen und dem was sie aus
dem ausland kaufen nun das merkmal des
vereinigten königreichs ist dass es für
einen sehr langen zeitraum ein defizit
von etwas hatte das als sichtbare
handelsbilanz bezeichnet wird die dinge
handelt die sie sehen können das sind
also waren die man erkennen würde dinge
die man in container stecken kann es
sind autos computer dinge die man in
einem geschäft sehen würde das war ein
erhebliches defizit
ich denke es öffnete sich in den frühen
1980 er jahren und im wesentlichen ist
es seitdem nicht verschwunden wenn
überhaupt ist es größer und größer
geworden
devisen reserven können nicht direkt für
inländische ausgaben verwendet werden
das geld kann nur im ausland oder für
importe aus gegeben werden ein land mit
einem großen handelsbilanzdefizit ist
darauf angewiesen dass seine gläubiger
die auf ihrem eigenen markt
aufgelaufenen ungleichgewichte ausgeben
in der vergangenheit gab es vorschläge
einen mechanismus zu schaffen mit dem
diese ungleichgewichte ausgeglichen
werden können zum beispiel john maynard
keynes am ende des zweiten weltkriegs
sein ursprünglicher vorschlag für das
was bretton woods und die dort
angesiedelten institutionen wie der iwf
und die weltbank wurden war dass es eine
art internationale clearing linien geben
würde diese bezog sich insbesondere auf
die handelsseite und nicht direkt auf
die finanzielle seite aber das prinzip
war das sobald sich die handelsbilanzen
geöffnet hätten jeder über eine
internationale clearingbank spielen
würde und das würde jeden zwingen die
ungleichgewichte die in der
realwirtschaft auftraten schließlich ins
gleichgewicht zu bringen
aber so einen mechanismus gibt es nicht
das kumulierte netto
handelsungleichgewicht des vereinigten
königreichs beträgt rund 800 milliarden
währungskriege im wesentlichen ist es so
dass einige länder über viele jahre
hinweg große handelsüberschüsse und
andere große handelsdefizite hatten die
länder mit handels defiziten haben mehr
ausgegeben als sie verdient haben also
mussten sie kredite aus dem ausland
aufnehmen und das haben sie jahr für
jahr getan länder wie dieses die
vereinigten staaten wir selbst und
einige andere länder in europa das kann
so nicht weitergehen und es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten wie das zu einem ende
kommen kann eine möglichkeit wäre und
wir haben das in einigen ländern in
europa gesehen wenn sie keine neuen wege
finden um wettbewerbsfähig zu werden
dann wird ihre fähigkeit die schulden
zurückzuzahlen infrage gestellt eine
andere möglichkeit das zu tun ist dass
wir einen glaubwürdigen plan zur
rückzahlung unserer schulden haben und
der wert des pfund sterling um 25
prozent gefallen ist um unsere exporte
für ausländische käufer
wettbewerbsfähiger und begehrenswerter
zu machen und es für britische
verbraucher attraktiver zu machen von
britischen produzenten zu kaufen anstatt
von ausländischen produzenten
das ist es was wir getan haben um einen
rahmen zu schaffen unsere wirtschaft
wieder ins gleichgewicht zu bringen
währungskrieg auch bekannt als
kompetitiven abwertung ist eine
bedingung in der länder gegeneinander
konkurrieren um einen relativ niedrigen
wechselkurs für ihre währung zu
erreichen wenn der preis für den kauf
einer bestimmten währung fällt sinkt
auch der reale preis der exporte aus
diesem land die heimische industrie
erhält sowohl im in als auch im ausland
einen nachfrageschub
es hat die britischen exporte ziemlich
billig erscheinen lassen so dass sie
sich ein wenig erholt haben aber
irgendwann fielen sie wieder was wir
also sehen ist eine art anarchie und in
gewisser weise eine zunehmende anarchie
das ist es was in den letzten jahren
passiert ist vorüber der brasilianische
finanzminister am lautesten gesprochen
hat gespräche über währungskriege und
über den wunsch der nationalen
regierungen wenn sie mit einer großen
rezession konfrontiert sind denken sie
wenn wir mehr exportieren könnten
könnten wir uns aus dieser rezession
befreien wenn wir mehr exportieren
wollen wir hatten wir unsere währung ab
das macht unsere waren billiger alle
anderen kaufen sie und wir werden alle
besser dran sein das problem hier ist
wenn sie abwerten ist es als ob alle
anderen gegen sie abwerten deren sachen
werden teurer also sind sie nicht
glücklich darüber sie wollen dann auch
entfernten und hier entwickelt sich eine
abwertungsspirale
um den wert ihrer landeswährung zu
verringern verkauft eine nationale
zentralbank reservewährung auf dem markt
es erzeugt diese währung aus dem nichts
in dem es zahlen in einen computer
eingibt das heißt eine zentralbank auf
der wiesn der betrag den eine
zentralbank schaffen kann es nicht
begrenzt weil es keine definierten wert
hinter der reserve währung gibt
während der langen phase des wahren
geldes wurde der wechselkurs durch die
menge an gold silber und kupfer in den
münzen der einzelnen länder bestimmt
auch nach der einführung von papiergeld
und dem gold stand hat war der
wechselkurs abhängig von der
versprochenen menge an gold die die
regierung einem besitzer einer banknote
zahlen würde diese beträge schwankten
kurzfristig kaum und wechselkurse
zwischen währungen waren relativ stabil
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg waren
währungen an den dollar gekoppelt und
der dollar war durch gold gedeckt dieses
system endete
wir haben ein modernes finanzsystem in
dem geld chaotisch organisiert ist es
gibt keinen wechselkurs da es keinen
goldstandard zu erhalten gilt wir
brauchen also keine wir glauben dass der
markt alle probleme des tausches lösen
wird ob ihre währung mehr wert sein
sollte als meine ist eine spiegelung der
stärke ihrer wirtschaft im vergleich zu
meiner sollte sich das verhältnis ändern
kann sich der index für währungs
wechselkurse ändern es geschieht auf
magische weise durch die effizienz des
marktes und profitstreben ihr kennt den
rest denke ich
[Musik]
der wert einer währung in bezug auf eine
andere währung wird durch den markt
bestimmt wenn mehr leute eine währung
kaufen als verkaufen wollen dann steigt
ihr wert wenn mehr leute verkaufen
wollen dann sinkt ihr wert der wert wird
von einzelnen banken festgelegt die
währungen kaufen und verkaufen sie
passen den wechselkurs an
die letzte studie die ich 2007 jeden tag
über die devisenmärkte gelesen habe
zeigt es werden jeden tag 3,2 billionen
dollar gehandelt wer weiß was das
globale bip ist
50 millionen dollar 50 noch mal höher 60
60 das ist näher dran
überlegen sie dass diese menge jeden tag
gehandelt wird es gibt ungefähr 260
werktage im jahr es dauert ein paar
wochen um dem globalen wert jeder
wirtschaftlichen leistung die überall
jeden tag ein jahr lang erbracht wird
gleich zu kommen
es dauert ein paar wochen ein jeder von
uns handelt offensichtlich ziemlich
regelmäßig mit währungen wenn sie
verreisen tauschen sie sie in eine
andere währung um das ist eine art von
währungshandel sie tauschen ihre pfund
in euro yen oder was auch immer es sein
mag das passiert ziemlich häufig und das
ist ein konventioneller teil des handels
prozesses große unternehmen müssen
regelmäßig umtauschen was menschen
allerdings infrage stellen wenn sie
sagen moment das ist spekulation nämlich
wenn sie realisieren dass währungen sich
nebeneinander bewegen und wenn sie sich
im wert nebeneinander bewegen dann gibt
es immer eine chance versuchen geld aus
der veränderung des wertes zu machen das
ist der teil des marktes denen eine
finanztransaktionssteuer versuchen würde
einzudämmen weil die nicht gänzlich
falsche annahme ist dass es nur
instabilität für alle anderen verursacht
diese menschen wollen volatilität im
markt denn so verdienen sie ihr geld
sie wollen sie verstärken und verstärken
sie indem sie so handeln und spekulieren
wie sie es tun
bis zum jahr 2010 war der devisenmarkt
zum größten und flüssig ssten der welt
angewachsen durchschnittlich 4 billionen
dollar in währungen wurden jeden tag
gehandelt
volatilität verursacht not was macht es
mit ländern vielleicht besonders kleinen
entwicklungsländern wenn auf einmal
riesige und ständig schwankende
finanzströme kommen
was können sie tun um damit umzugehen
die produktion erhöhen und mehr
verkaufen die preise senken und
möglicherweise noch ärmer werden
wenn man anfängt über das internationale
system zu reden wird es schnell
eigenartig viel davon hängt von
empfindungen und meinungen darüber ab
wie es um eine wirtschaft steht mehr als
es davon abhängt was eine wirtschaft
tatsächlich tut oder nicht tut das kann
sich sehr schnell verschieben denn wenn
es nur um jemandes meinung geht ob eine
währung tragbar ist dann kann man das
glauben so lange man will wenn sich
diese meinung ändert und an den
finanzmärkten kann sie sich sehr schnell
ändern kann es innerhalb von minuten
sogar sekunden zu dem prozess der
finanziellen ansteckung kommen so können
sie von einer scheinbar stabilen
robusten wirtschaft zu einer werden
gegen die sich plötzlich die stimmung
wendet und auf einmal merken sie dass
die märkte es auf sie abgesehen haben
oft braucht es nicht mehr als dass sie
der nachbar eines landes sind das in
schwierigkeiten ist
viele der weltweiten finanzkrisen der
letzten 30 jahre wurden durch den
hastigen abzug der währung eines landes
oder einer ganzen region verursacht
diese art von aktivität wird oft als
finanzielle kriegsführung bezeichnet
davon haben bedeutende institutionen
erheblich profitiert wie goldman sachs
zum beispiel jeder größeren bank ging es
aufgrund dieser art von regelungen
besser als es in einem regulierten
umfeld der fall gewesen wäre es hat
bestimmt leute sehr sehr reich gemacht
es hat den finanzmärkten eine enorme
expansion ermöglicht jeder daran
beteiligte ist scharf auf eine
deregulierte welt im falle von england
haben sie eine regierung die ziemlich
offen vorsätzlich und aggressiv gegen
jegliche form der regulierung der
finanzmärkte argumentiert hat aber es
ist nicht der fall dass jemand hinter
den kulissen die fäden zieht so laufen
die dinge abgeholt und offen direkt vor
ihren augen so ist die welt nun mal
manche menschen macht das sehr reich und
die sind recht zufrieden damit
wie ich denke es ist eine art von
unwirtschaftlicher kriegsführung ein
großteil der veränderung der letzten 30
jahre in der art wie die weltwirtschaft
funktioniert resultiert aus den schulden
der entwicklungsländer weil es den
reichen ländern den banken und im
finanzsektor enorme macht und kontrolle
über die ärmeren regionen der welt
gegeben hat in denen es eine große menge
an ressourcen gibt die wir gerne
verbrauchen
das ganze in einer weise die viele leute
mit einer form des kolonialismus
vergleichen es ist eine sehr direkte art
von macht um diese länder zu dingen zu
zwingen die im interesse der reichsten
länder der welt sind
infolgedessen sind nicht nur die
konzerne unglaublich profitabel groß
mächtig und alles durchdringend geworden
sondern die finanz branche ist sogar
noch größer geworden
richtig geld verdienen tut man heute
nicht indem man etwas herstellt sondern
einfach durch bestimmte formen der
spekulation geld aus geld machen dass es
die profitabelste und bei weitem größte
wirtschaftliche aktivität die es heute
auf der welt gibt
um sich zu schützen müssen sich
gefährdete länder mit währungen der
reichen länder eindecken diese stellen
die währungen aus dem nichts mehr
die niederlande der erste general
gouverneur von indonesien der mann der
die handelswege aufgebaut hat wie es
ihnen entlang festungen errichten und
bekämpfte spanische und britische
flotten
bezüglich des niederländischen imperiums
und handelns sagte er wir können keinen
handel betreiben ohne krieg und keinen
krieg führen ohne handel
geld und macht
finanzieller imperialismus
reserven sind zu einer art versicherung
geworden wo gegen spekulation sie hatten
spekulationen gesagt einen spekulativen
angriff fallende märkte blasen
wenn ein land einem angriff der
spekulation er liegt dann wird eine
deregulierung seiner märkte verlangt um
sein finanzsystem dem der dominierenden
partei anzupassen
den meisten entwicklungsländern die in
eine finanzkrise geraten sind wird von
den höheren mächten der welt dem iwf der
in vielerlei hinsicht das globale
finanzsystem regiert gesagt dass der weg
aus den schulden eine restrukturierung
der wirtschaft sei besonders die exporte
zu erhöhen um mehr dollar zu verdienen
dann können sie ihre schulden in dollar
oder einer anderen fremden währung
zurückzahlen leider wurde immer und
immer wieder bewiesen dass das ganz und
gar nicht der fall ist diese länder
haben ihre öffentlichen ausgaben auf ein
minimum reduziert das wachstum und das
wachstumspotenzial kamen zum stillstand
und was sie herstellten war für die
exportmärkte bestimmt um an dollar zu
kommen sie haben ihre schulden abbezahlt
haben aber ihre eigene wirtschaft nicht
entwickelt die schuldentilgung betrug
weit mehr als sie für gesundheit bildung
oder sonst etwas ausgaben und ihre
schulden wuchsen und wuchsen weiter
das land wird zu einem vasallenstaat der
es den großen konzernen ermöglicht die
natürlichen ressourcen und die
arbeitskräfte auszubeuten finanzieller
imperialismus ausbau und pflege der
kolonialen macht durch finanzielle
dominanz
es ist kein großes geheimnis was hier
passiert und wie die welt läuft es ist
ziemlich unverblümt seit den letzten 30
jahren breitet sich überall etwas aus
was meistens neoliberalismus genannt
wird eine idee von flexiblen
wechselkursen schwache regulierung
besonders der finanzmärkte minimale
staatliche einmischung in die märkte und
so funktioniert die welt mehr oder
weniger und dann gibt es diese
institutionen eine bedeutsame derzeit
ist der iwf die versuchen diese
situation zu erzwingen das ist also
nicht sonderlich obskur als ob menschen
im hintergrund die fäden ziehen sondern
es ist ziemlich offensichtlich es
passiert und zwar so schon seit ich
erwachsen bin wie es aussieht ist das
wie die welt funktioniert und es hat
einige menschen sehr reich gemacht das
hat enorme konzentrationen von vermögen
verursacht
wenn der internationale währungsfond
eingreift um die schulden eines landes
in den griff zu bekommen dann sind daran
konditionen geknüpft in den 1980 er und
90 er jahren haben sie es strukturelles
anpassungsprogramm genannt es neigt dazu
ähnliche formen anzunehmen egal wo es
passiert wir können strukturelle
anpassungsprogramme heute in
griechenland portugal und irland
beobachten länder werden angehalten die
öffentlichen ausgaben zu senken
sie werden angewiesen ihre handels- und
kapitalmärkte zu liberalisieren geld
kann so sehr viel leichter in und aus
der wirtschaft strömen das soll
investitionen aus reicheren teilen der
welt anlocken und all ihre probleme
lösen in wirklichkeit hat sich immer
wieder herausgestellt dass das
vollkommen unbegründet ist
[Musik]
tatsächlich hat das aufkommen der
industrien und kapazitäten in diesen
entwicklungsländern zerstört die
entwicklungsländer wurden komplett von
gütern und dienstleistungen entwickelter
länder abhängig und auch von deren
kapital eine sache auf die der iwf
besonders besteht es die senkung der
steuern die multinationale konzerne
bezahlen müssen wenn sie dort ihren
betrieb aufnehmen denn so locken sie
mehr multinationale konzerne an
natürlich bedeutet das auch dass die
gewinne der konzerne das land ebenso
schnell verlassen das land selbst
profitiert davon nicht heute haben sie
viele entwicklungsländer die fast kein
steueraufkommen haben sie sind also noch
abhängiger von den internationalen
finanzmärkten den geldmärkten vom
schuldenmachen deshalb gibt es so viele
länder auf der welt die ära souveränität
beraubt wurden wie soll sich eine
demokratische gesellschaft entwickeln
oder funktionieren wenn eine regierung
abhängiger vom iwf und den geldmärkten
ist als von ihrem eigenen volk
finanzinstrumente
was wir seit den 1970 er jahren sehen
ist eine dramatische zunahme eine reihe
von phänomenen die eine stimulierende
wirkung auf die veränderungen im
finanzsystem hatten die uns zu dem
glänzenden metall und stahlgeschäft
gebracht haben das da drüben ist weil
sie nicht wissen was ich zeige auf die
city of london
um das fehlen eines definierten rohstoff
basierten wertes zu kompensieren der
währungen zu grunde liegt entwickelten
finanzinstitute verbriefungen als mittel
zur risikosteuerung sie entwickeln
verbriefungen als mittel um zu versuchen
das gesamte system zu stabilisieren
das ist eine reihe von finanz prinzessin
und finanzinnovationen die sich seit den
70er und 80er jahren wirklich
beschleunigen sie hatten ein chaotisches
system dass risiken managen und
innovativ sein musste man brauchte
derivate optionen futures
sie haben neue märkte für volatilitäts
management-tools wer weiß was der
begriff hecking ist das risiko streuen
managen sie ihr risiko versichern sie
sich dagegen genau bis in die 1960 er
jahre hinein äußerte sich die securities
and exchange commission ganz deutlich
dass derivate die nicht auf echten
produkten wie solchen aus der
landwirtschaft also schweinebauch
futures oder etwas ähnlichem rasieren
glücksspiel wären und somit der handel
mit solchen derivaten untersagt ist das
veränderte sich in den 1960 er jahre
jeder konnte mit währungs futures
handeln dingen die nicht auf fan-festen
produkte basieren die zu einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt in der zukunft
gehandelt werden sondern auch
schwankungen von währungs preisen als
das system der fixen wechselkurse
zusammenbricht beschleunigt sich diese
sache natürlich enorm wo staatliche
regulierungen abgebaut werden übernimmt
der markt mit seinen eigenen produkten
die theorie besagt dass der markt sich
besser selbst reguliert die hypothese
von den effizienten märkten ist die idee
dass man einen finanzmarkt aufbaut der
schnell ist alle sind gut informiert
alle beobachten ganz genau was jeder
andere tut daher wird er sehr stabil
sein und er spiegelt tatsächliche
veränderungen in der wirtschaft wieder
er wird nicht von paniken man ihn und
spekulationsblasen angetrieben wenn es
auf und abwärtsbewegungen gibt dann nur
weil tatsächlich etwas passiert worauf
händler und investoren in den
finanzmärkten lediglich reagieren das
ist die hypothese von den effizienten
märkten und ich glaube 2008 ist auf eine
art das ende dieses prozesses das
auftreten einer so gewaltigen krise dass
der glaube sie sei selbst stabilisierend
und regulierend nicht aufrechterhalten
werden kann die methode wird sowieso
weiter angewendet aber man kann nicht
mehr wie zuvor argumentieren sie sei gut
oder notwendig oder sie sei okay für die
welt
in den letzten zehn jahren hatten wir
eine weitere innovation etwas das als
credit default swap bezeichnet wird eine
möglichkeit eine versicherung gegen ein
unternehmen zu kaufen das sie investiert
haben um pleitezugehen im jahr 2002
betrugen sie weniger als eine billion
dollar im jahr 2007 waren es 60
millionen dollar dazwischen liegen fünf
jahre
plötzlich sitzen alle da und sagen oh
dieses videos die wir gemacht haben
bieten tatsächlich nicht die art von
stabilität die wir dachten die
mathematik die in ihnen steckt ist
völliger unsinn wie sich herausstellt
der versuch risiken und schulden so zu
verbriefen wie wir es getan haben ist
mit weitaus größeren risiken verbunden
als wir dachten und wir denken jetzt
dass diese dinge wertlos sind
der versuch immer komplexere wege zur
regulierung und gestaltung eines
finanzmarktes zu finden und zu versuchen
auch schnelles geld daraus zu machen
trug tatsächlich dazu bei den
gegenteiligen effekt zudem zu erzielen
was seine befürworter sagten nämlich
dass es zu einem spektakulären crash
führte
was wir als ergebnis dieser sehr anderen
situation gesehen haben war vor allem
ein phänomen ein sektor ist vor allem
gewachsen und das war der finanzsektor
während der finanzsektor enorm vom
gegenwärtigen währungssystem profitiert
ist das system weder stabil noch fair
wie es sonst die annahme bei dem was die
bank of england im moment tut ist dass
das bargeld das wir haben durch die
staatsschulden gedeckt ist die regierung
kann ihr versprechen dadurch bekräftigen
dass es steuern erheben kann was sie
damit andeuten ist dass das bargeld
durch staatsschulden gedeckt ist während
staatsschulden durch die fähigkeit der
regierung bargeld von den steuerzahlern
zu kriegen gedeckt sind
in den letzten 30 jahren wurden private
schulden immer wieder in staatsschulden
verwandelt letztlich wird der preis für
die schulden von der öffentlichkeit im
schuldner lang bezahlt
deshalb sind ausgabenkürzungen notwendig
das system soll bestimmte menschen auf
kosten der bürger und steuerzahler einer
nation sehr reich machen das system
senkt im lebensstandard der mehrheit und
verteilt diesen reichtum unter den
privilegierten
übrig bleibt seit den 70er jahren ein
finanzsystem ohne fixe wechselkurse das
plötzlich zunehmend offene grenzen für
capital hat
dass zentralbanken hat die ohne
kontrolle verwalten müssen da nichts ist
wo früher das gold war
die chaotische expansive geldpolitik
betreiben müssen die als kreditgeber
letzter instanz einspringen müssen
im laufe der geschichte wurden
geldsysteme entworfen um der dominanten
internationalen macht einen vorteil zu
verschaffen und diese macht wird heftig
verteidigt und erweitert
internationale währungsreform
was ich gerne sehen würde ist eine neue
art der währung die durch etwas gestützt
gerta selten ist und dass wir wirklich
brauchen und wir wirklich schätzen so
etwas wie energie oder erneuerbare
energie zum beispiel eine auf
kilowattstunden basierte währung wäre
sehr interessant für mich wir müssen
anfangen die dinge zu schätzen die am
seltensten sind und dass wir als
menschliche spezies auf lange sicht
überleben müssen eine internationale
währung auf so etwas zu stützen wird
enorme investitionen in zb erneuerbare
energien zur folge haben wenn das die
primäre international gebrauchte
berechnungs einheit wird eine weitere
option ist ein korb von währungen bei
dem der wert verschiedener währungen
vermischt wird um eine sehr solide
währung zu schaffen in die die menschen
vertrauen haben
vielleicht wäre ein korb von rohstoffen
mit dem inter- nationale währungen
gesichert werden können noch besser
wenn es irgendwie international möglich
wäre die zunehmend konkurrierenden
nationalen volkswirtschaften
zusammenzubringen um eine vereinbarung
ähnlich der von brad not zu schreiben
die im gegensatz zu bretton woods
erlaubt einige währungen an verschiedene
körper von gütern zu binden die zu ihren
nationalen volkswirtschaften passen wenn
man das arrangieren könnte wäre das fein
man könnte beobachten wie das eine art
ordnung in die internationale
makroökonomie bringen würde die ihr
ansonsten fehlt die wirkliche
schwierigkeit dabei ist politisch wer
auf der welt macht es wer ist die
kaufkraft die das geschehen macht
die schaffung eines geldsystems dass
sowohl faire als auch stabil ist ist
möglich und kann erreicht werden wozu
dienen internationale organisationen
wenn nicht für einen solchen zweck
woher kommt das geld ein teil des weiß
auf was für diesen dokumentarfilm stammt
aus diesem buch
das ist george
george arbeitete in einer großen bank in
der city of london
aber eines tages ging georgias bank ohne
vorwarnung pleite lackleder
glücklicherweise rettete die regierung
die bank und george behielt seinen job
aber die gierige regierung wollte etwas
als gegenleistung für ihre hilfe sie
forderte eine höhere steuer auf george s
gehalt und boni für jemanden mit einem
kostspieligen lebensstil wie george kann
ein schock für dieser verheerend sein
jetzt kämpft darum sich die miete für
seine wohnung am flussufer im zentrum
von london zu leisten die reifen seines
ersten matten sind abgefahren und kaum
straßentauglich es sei denn george
situation verbessert sich oder jemand
wie sie hilft ihm denn george ist
vielleicht sogar gezwungen an den
semmelroth schneidern vorbeizugehen und
seinen anzug bei topshop oder next zu
kaufen
selbst wenn george etwas zu feiern hätte
kann er sich den champagner zum feiern
nicht mehr leisten
george ist nicht allein
unzählige andere leiden wie er niemand
weiß wie lange es dauern wird bis die
guten zeiten wieder kehren
[Musik]
aber mit ihrer hilfe kann george sein
leben umkrempeln
eine kleine monatliche spende von ihnen
kann ein bisschen sonnenschein in george
s leben zurückbringen
nur 395 punkt könnten ihm helfen
kleinere erfolge mit einer magnumflasche
champagner zu feiern bereits 900 pfund
würden george helfen einen neuen satz
reifen für seinen aston martin zu kaufen
2000 und können george helfen sein
selbstwertgefühl mit einem anzug von
einem renommierten semmelroth schneider
wieder zu erlangen aber auch ein
kleinerer betrag kann helfen
nur 200 pfund kann george eine mahlzeit
versichern seine freundin kaufen nur 200
extra für die getränke
wenn sie eine patenschaft für einen
banker übernehmen unterstützen sie nicht
nur jemanden wie george in einer zeit
der not sie unterstützen auch die
trendigen weinbars der city of london
die luxusautohersteller italiens und die
schneider von savary sie würden ihre
patriotische pflicht tun großbritanniens
größte industrie in ihrer zeit der not
zu unterstützen
und wenn die guten zeiten wiederkehren
und george seinen bonus zurückbekommt
werden die steuern die er zahl dazu
beitragen die öffentlichen
dienstleistungen zu finanzieren von
denen der rest von euch noch an abhängt
also bitte dass die guten zeiten für
george und seinesgleichen zurückkehren
während sie bereit etwas zu spenden
[Musik]